the Gallup made an extensive surveying
32 Muslim countries and it came out with
a result like 93% of the Muslims in
these 32 Muslim countries they condemned
the rejected 911 and they condemned
every form of suicide bombing from Quran
there is no way of supporting suicide
bombing it is the only religious
scripture where Allah says in for a
massage for a number for as number 29 do
not kill your own life with your own
hands meaning do not commit suicide no
other leader scripture has an equivalent
statement Allah says you cannot commit
suicide so forget suicide bombing every
form of suicide bombing in Islam is
haram and what is referred as son of
Egypt its corners of Saudi Arabia if you
go to the top of the line of the
scholars share bin bars who was the
Grand Mufti for a very long time you
talk about Nasiruddin albani you talk
about Simon she who same info t Arabia
the three top most of the line they
strongly condemn suicide bombing these
three scholars they have given fatwa on
more than 72 pages saying that Osama bin
Laden and his likes are terrorists
there's no I'd have supported this when
it comes to Middle East problems Robert
Pape when he was studying Robert paper
has written a book by the name dying to
win he's an expert now I'm here
especially in suicide bombing he has
written a book the dying to win and it's
a central research book on suicide
bombing for agencies to study he says
out of the 315 completed suicide
bombings from nineteen hundred and
eighty-two 2005 more than ninety percent
were committed only against foreign
occupation as the reason so this is the
root cause now because he says the root
cause of suicide bombing if you want to
know why these people are dear some that
Islam also condemned that expert on
suicide bombing days in his study he has
come across as more than ninety percent
of the suicide moments were committed
not in the name of religion but as a
result of foreign occupation on their
territory on there
or on their land this is what he says
and then he continues to say more than
fifty percent of the suite eight
bombings were not committed by Muslims
they were committed by non-muslim groups
like ltte like the IRA irish republican
army which is a strong Christian
background army and the peak a group of
turkey which is a socialist communist
group and not a religious group these
are the three most committing suicide
moments in the world the time of tigers
are they also a part of this there any
of course the other ones ltte yeah
they're regular circular room they're
articular group pj/k the secular
absolutely if you find individual even
find an entity a lot of the people who
say we are Hindus but I know Hinduism of
course they're not promote violence in
this form of suicide bombing absolutely
not yeah so these people they are not
Muslims and this is what Robert paid
phase and the other storing thing that
has been fun out on American soil by
gallup survey and other surveys by the
FBI the report says from sales 911 till
date the muslims were involved only in
six percent of terrorist attacks five
percent by the communists six seven
percent by the Jews forty-three percent
and twenty four percent by the latinos
and the white supremacist groups yeah so
we did the muslims do it even on the
American soil so what's happening in the
Middle East we all know who studied the
problem from where did it start when it
comes to Isis is is I think this is the
first time ever in the recent past you
saw all the Muslim scholars from all
Muslim groups coming together
unanimously condemning Isis saying they
have nothing to do with Islam and we
have been very very vocal about it
[Applause]